so he will
um i will ask him to present his interns
if if he's available to do so i also
know he's got some um
other commitments during this time
um anyways i want to welcome everyone to
our
thursday research conference and as
always happens at the end of the summer
we will have presentations from our
summer interns and talk about the work
that they did over the summer
we have
90 minutes for three
uh interns um so they'll talk um
uh perhaps up to however long they've
prepared maybe 20 minutes or so and then
there'll be some time for a question and
answer
um just before we start um uh most of
you probably saw the uh unfortunate news
that the university is going back to
restricted operations due to the uh
delta
delta spike
so um
we will be continuing these virtual
sorts of activities for the foreseeable
future probably for the rest of the
calendar year
and hopefully
things will will turn around quickly um
okay well i think at this point um maybe
i will turn over the floor to dr door
and he can introduce ellie chang
uh great thanks uh we've been pleased to
have ellie i've asked my interns to
introduce themselves um so ellie why
don't you just take it away
all right sounds good
okay is this working
okay
hi everyone um my name is ellie and i'm
currently an intern here at ohsu over
the summer
i'm a rising junior at princeton
studying computer science
and today i'll be talking to you all
about the project i've been working on
this summer with the high blood pressure
team
i would like to start by thanking
everyone who not only made this
internship experience possible but also
incredibly enjoyable and fun
i would specifically like to acknowledge
the high blood pressure team including
my mentor dr dorr along with the rest of
the care management plus team and also
the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology
first i'll introduce the high blood
pressure project and then talk about the
specific projects i've been working on
this summer
nearly half of adults in the united
states have high blood pressure also
called hypertension
according to the cdc only one in four
adults with hypertension have controlled
blood pressure uncontrolled blood
pressure increases the risk of heart
disease and stroke which are two of the
leading causes of of death for older
adults
although clinical guidelines for the
treatment of hypertension represent a
wide breadth of biomedical knowledge the
implementation of these guidelines is
still inconsistent and resource
intensive
guidelines often conflict on the
appropriate diagnosis and treatment of
hypertension even definitions for what
blood pressure measurements constitute
stage 1 and stage 2 hypertension are
varied
these inconsis
consistencies require leveraging
provider experience gathering and
assessing knowledge and data manually
and attempting to integrate many
distinct factors and options often
resulting in inadequate hypertension
management for patients
additionally similarly to many common
conditions there is a plethora of
decisions made from diagnosis to
treatment
decisions that despite involving health
care providers are largely dependent on
the individual patient for example a
patient's other pre-existing health
conditions side effects and demographic
factors can significantly influence the
approach needed for effective treatment
in addition behavioral and lifestyle
factors such as alcohol consumption and
physical activity can also substantially
affect treatment and outcome
the ability to create computable and
personalized guideline-based
recommendations would not only shorten
timelines and reduce required resources
but would also improve overall care
as such the high blood pressure team has
been developing a patient-facing
clinical decision support or cds tool
that translates hypertension guidelines
into practice using clinical query
language or cql modules
these modules incorporate personalized
patient preferences through direct usage
by patients
this approach elicits the information
needed for patient facing clinical
decision support as well as
appropriately allows patients to
self-assess treatment progress and
adherence through a workflow sensitive
solution
specific innovations in this project
include the use of blood pressure sets
to match guidelines a counseling goal
and preference system for
non-pharmacologic recommendations and
specific patient and care team versions
of the recommendations
as an integral part of this project we
created recommendations that patients
will be given based on their engagement
with the tool
in total we use eight clinical
guidelines that encompass 71
recommendations as the foundation for
the logic behind six different workflows
the diagram here shows a brief overview
of how the app works
when a provider orders home blood
pressure monitoring the patient is
introduced to the app which will give
them different recommendations that
allow them to take action
the data that is pulled in and used to
drive the recommendations comes from
electronic health records as well as
engagement with the app itself
clinical quality framework or cqf ruler
uses cql to encode the logic to generate
cards which are the recommendations that
patients and care teams are shown
over this past summer we have been
working mostly on developing the initial
diagnosis and monitoring workflow as
well as the non-pharmacologic
interventions workflow which will be
shown on the next slide
the initial diagnosis and monitoring
workflow as shown here makes an initial
evaluation based on a patient's set of
blood pressure readings and then shows
the patient a recommendation associated
with this evaluation
for patients with high blood pressure
who have not been diagnosed with
hypertension the tool considers a
possible diagnosis for the patient and
the patient is recommended to reach out
to their care team to confirm the
diagnosis
as mentioned earlier the workflows use
blood pressure sets which is defined as
at least four office or six home blood
pressure measurements
if the patient does not have a full set
of measurements they are recommended to
take measurements first
using a set of blood pressure readings
to make a tentative diagnosis is crucial
because according to one study done in
2020
not having enough measurements leads to
a much higher risk of over diagnosis
having a fixed definition of a set would
reduce this risk
additionally patients who are monitoring
their blood pressure at home may get a
high blood pressure reading and become
worried about the reading
because they might not fully understand
what the value means having this app at
home may help alleviate concerns because
it can tell them exactly what the
reading means and what their immediate
next steps should be or perhaps it may
let them know that the worry is
unfounded
for patients already diagnosed with
hypertension who also have an unmet
blood pressure goal the tool might
suggest non-pharmacologic interventions
through this workflow if such
interventions are deemed applicable for
the patient
for some patients pharmacologic
solutions are the best first step to
controlling their blood pressure but
often non-pharmacologic therapies are
key
the non-pharmacologic workflow on the
left involves the output of five
different sub workflows tobacco
cessation weight loss alcohol moderation
physical activity and nutrition
given specific information about the
individual patient the patient is shown
sub-workloads relevant to their own
behavior for example if the patient is
recorded to be a current smoker the tool
would go to the tobacco cessation
sub-workflow as shown on the right
since the engagement aspect of the tool
is really important the app asks the
patient to set different behavior goals
relating to these non-pharmacologic
interventions and then proceeds to keep
track of their progress
there's a lot of evidence that showed
the effectiveness of non-pharmacologic
interventions and controlling blood
pressure but these interventions often
don't get implemented effectively in a
clinical setting
the app this team is developing is
unique because it encourages patients to
implement these non-pharmacologic
therapies independently or alongside
their care teams
through self-management support
along with the app the project involves
creating an implementation guide so that
clinics who might use the tool in the
future can best understand why certain
decisions were made in the creation
process to balance clinical reasoning
with the pragmatic approach to
programming the app
ultimately the implementation guide will
allow for people to implement the tool
most effectively
this summer i worked on writing up
functional descriptions of the workflows
i showed in the previous slides for this
implementation guide translating the
workflows into a readable paragraph
format
an example description is shown on the
right side of the slide
the functional descriptions are
equivalent to a line-by-line set of
comments for code that allow the reader
to understand the purpose of each line
the reader of the implementation guide
would be able to read the description
and understand the logic of the workflow
and understand how exactly it fits into
the tool
working on these descriptions really
helped me familiarize myself with the
logic of the workflows and helped me a
lot when working on the actual
recommendations the patients would be
given
all the recommendations are compiled
into this excel file each row shows a
distinct recommendation or cds card with
the patient and care team versions of
the text along with other informational
columns about the recommendation that
are not shown in this slide
the work i did focus specifically on the
recommendations that are shown to the
patients the way that these
recommendations are presented to
patients is critical because it
determines how they understand and
respond to it
i revise the text to be more concise and
easier to understand for people who may
have little to no knowledge about
hypertension i also found links to
additional resources that would be
helpful for patients to use whether that
was providing supplemental information
to help the patient understand more
about their condition or information
about how to get started on certain
non-pharmaco pharmacologic therapy such
as low sodium diets
the recommendations encourage patients
to work alongside their care team in the
treatment process in the hopes of
empowering the patients to manage their
own care
shown in this slide is an example of a
page of recommendations that a patient
might see
this html was generated by the app from
a json response file of a test patient
using the tool there are three
recommendations shown here but each one
has a similar structure
the colored circle on the left shows the
indicator status of the recommendation
green for informational and orange for
warning the recommendation summary is
the bolded text at the top of each
recommendation and the patient text that
i revised is shown below that
each recommendation also has suggestion
types associated with it that are
recorded in the recommendations row in
the excel file i showed earlier
in the first recommendation shown the
patient has a blood pressure goal that
they have not reached so the type
associated with the recommendation is a
suggestion link shown on the right side
of the page with a link to contact the
patient's care team to continue
treatment in the second recommendation
shown we see that the patient is also a
smoker who has not received counseling
for smoking cessation so they are shown
a recommendation with a counseling link
type
this counseling link is shown below the
patient text as a link to relevant
resources
this patient has not set a smoking
cessation goal so the recommendation
also has a goal type
as such on the right side of this
recommendation they are given different
options to set a goal to reduce smoking
essentially the structure of each
recommendation is determined by its
suggestion types
in the actual app the information taken
from the cds cards excel file shown in a
previous slide is translated to cql
modules and then a response json file
all this information then becomes the
actual html display or the user
interface that the patients see based on
the information fed to the tool
however we didn't have an efficient way
to quickly visualize and test the
individual recommendations the patients
would see
during my internship i worked on a small
project to fulfill this need the product
is a java program that uses the cds
cards excel file as input taking
information from a single target
recommendations excel row and produces
an html file corresponding to the target
recommendation essentially it takes an
excel file shown on the left and
converts it to the html file as shown on
the right
an example output is shown in this slide
the input for this program was the
recommendation number 23c which involves
diet counseling and goal setting the
excel row for this recommendation is
shown at the top of the slide and the
html display for the recommendation
which is what the program outputs is
shown at the bottom
the green circle at the left of the
display indicates that the
recommendation indicator is
informational the bolded text is the
recommendation summary and below that is
the patient text
as you can see this particular
recommendation has a counseling link
type which is shown as the link below
the recommendation for diet counseling
and on the right is the recommendations
goal type
the patient is given both a free text
option and a fixed set of choices to
select from for their diet goal which
gives the patient a bit of flexibility
the patient is also asked to pick a date
by which to reach their goal and then
commit to that goal
the structure of each recommendations
html that this particular program
generates emulates the structure of the
recommendations generated by the actual
app shown in the previous slide
this program will essentially allow us
to test and visualize each new
recommendation as soon as it is created
in the excel file
this would bypass any bugs or
troubleshooting that may arise in the
actual apps much more complex procedure
finally during my internship i drafted
up a poster for the 2022 american
medical informatics association summit
and if the submission is accepted i will
be able to go to the conference and
present there which would be incredibly
exciting
picking a few takeaways from my
internship i would say that my
experience here has given me so much
more knowledge about hypertension and
the difficulties that providers and
patients alike face during the treatment
process
additionally working on this project has
made me better understand the importance
of patient engagement and how giving a
patient more agency is a prerequisite to
the successful care of a condition like
hypertension
lastly i was able to pick up the basics
of cql and html while working on the
mini excel to html project
i think this internship has been really
helpful for me in terms of figuring out
my future career path as well i'm really
grateful to have had this opportunity
this summer to work with the cmp team on
the high blood pressure project so i
would like to thank everyone again so
much for making this experience possible
great thank you very interesting talk
are there any questions
from the audience
if not i will ask one um
i um
these it it's very um it's great to see
that the kind of emerging standards for
um moving information around between
um applications on the internet is
finally coming to fruition um even just
a few years ago um these standards were
not developed enough
to be able to do this did you encounter
any limitations of of any of the
standards like like fire or cds cards
that um
anything that you maybe wanted to do but
were not able to do because the
standards um were not
ready or mature enough
um not on the specific projects that i
was working on i think it was pretty
easy to
um
work on because like they're not really
any limitations to creating like
recommendations in the excel file and so
what i worked on was just like
translating that into the actual html
but i think a good limitation
um that dr doran i discussed earlier is
just that because so much of this is
moving online into things like
applications where patients can interact
with them there is a lot of like
potentially a digital divide
perhaps people
would find a tool like this not easy to
use or not be able to understand how to
use it or maybe don't even have the
technological resources to access it so
i think that is definitely one thing to
consider when moving forward
great
any other questions or comments
okay well thank you thank you very much
um and um
i too i'm hoping to get to the amia
summit meeting next spring
we'll see hopefully kovit will be behind
us and it will be great if you have an
opportunity to present
so um let's move ahead to our next
presenter who actually
spent the summer working with me
as an intern in
one of my research projects so our
second speaker is karen garcia who is a
sophomore
at portland state university
she's
local
lives in salem oregon
and
is also part of a program that some of
you are familiar with at portland state
called build exito
that
our department and dr cindy morris have
connection to that
aim to help people
move towards
careers in clinical research
so
karen is going to go ahead and present
oh sorry um i didn't realize i was muted
can everyone see my slides okay
yeah we can see them fine okay
so
as dr hirsch already mentioned i
name's karen and it's great to see you
all today and i
i was very lucky to be given the chance
to
delve a bit deeper into the world of
machine learning through the means of
this project
and
and an overview for this presentation
is going to
be about the purpose behind the trek
cobit project
a brief overview on information
retrieval and evaluation techniques
the trek covert haskells
questions examined through the text
through the threat coveted tasks so
you know what specific things are we
looking to um
solve
the trek cobot task steps the results
any difficulties that is encountered in
this study
and further plans and possible proposals
for the future
and finally the personal takeaways and
acknowledgments
so the purpose of this whole project
was that you know we're currently in the
digital age and news is spreading faster
than ever
uh
you know there are just hundreds and
hundreds of articles from various
different
um sources being churned out every
single day
and
within the covet 19 pandemic it was
evident how easy it is for news to um be
changed how easy it is for news to be
spread
um whether it's valid or not valid
and it's also evident how
life-threatening
this can be
as you can see you know facebook is a
common perpetrator
and then um
but even then um just with cases going
up
you know it's very hard to um
kind of have that peace of mind when it
comes to looking for information online
about
the
current pandemic
so
information retrieval is acquisition
organization and searching of knowledge
based information
and
this is the basis of the trekkobot
the trekkovic task
information retrieval is
used everywhere it's the basis of this
experiment
um
and basically um so the way it works say
when you go on google
you type in a few keyboards you type in
the question so that would be your
search query
and then
the information retrieval algorithm
sifts through hundreds or millions of
documents
and ranks them from which one is most
important
and then returns to the user the most
relevant ones
i guess in simple terms
so
and everybody engages with information
which people processes each day it's on
google it's on youtube it's everywhere
and
you know back
like at its first beginning stages it
was focused on text
and articles
but then it grew to
it grew to accommodate for videos and
various kinds of media
such as chemical structures
and dna sequences which is how it's
applied to the medical industry
so there are two types of retrieval the
first one is exact match
it returns all documents that match
exactly is what the user entered using
boolean operators
partial match
doesn't require boolean operators and
it's a little
it's a little bit more different and
then the information retrieval process
um looks like this so the user poses a
query
and then the search engine matches the
query to the metadata and the metadata
of an article of a link it contains
typically the
author of an article the date it was
published
and
um the file size and this metadata is
used
to um search through the files a lot
more efficiently and a lot more quickly
rather than having to um
use other inefficient methods
so an important way to evaluate if a
search engine is efficient
is
how first of all if the system is used
second
what was what is it used for
specifically
and third how well did someone use the
system
and if it's very user friendly
and if it's accessible
and for are the users satisfied
you know did they find what they were
looking for did they have an easy time
finding it and five what factors are
associated with successful or
unsuccessful use of the system
so
you know is it clear within the
algorithm
if
successful use um
you know how how are you going to
measure that and it's important to have
an idea
of how you're going to measure success
and success
with one of these algorithms and
six did the system have an impact did it
make anything
any easier within a research process
and then a really common type of system
oriented evaluation is recall
it's the number of retrieved and
relevant documents
over the number of divided by the number
of relevant documents in a database
and
then there's precision which is it gives
a fraction of how many relevant
documents there are from a specified
number of documents that were retrieved
rather so this is a bit more
um focused in scope it's not it doesn't
go over the entire database it's just
over the documents that were
specifically obtained
so now that you got some background
information on this
on these concepts um
trekkovid is a collaboration that
applies these concepts
for
medical journals
and it's a collaboration between the
university of texas
the national institute of standards of
technology
oregon health and science university in
the u.s national library of medicine
and the allen institute for ai
and it's meant to examine various
information retrieval methods
and how efficient they can be and how
good they are at obtaining the most
relevant and accurate articles
so peer reviewed articles are the golden
standard when it comes to
searching for medical information
they're trusted by experts all across
the field
everybody
uses them
and
with so many articles and so many
studies coming out every single day
the most important question is how are
health experts supposed to keep up with
what journal articles are most relevant
in an efficient
manner so how this task will improve
information retrieval is to reduce the
amount of time it takes to look for
reliable data
it also aims to search for the most
relevant reports by using comparison
algorithms
and ultimately aims to prevent the
spread of misinformation you know you
don't want a search engine to show you
data from
you know last week when it could show
you a report that came out an hour ago
you always want to make sure that the
comparison
um is as up-to-date as possible
and what is being accounted for in this
experiment so the first one is how to
choose the content to search through you
know what are you gonna test your
information retrieval algorithm on
and in this project it was tested on a
coven 19 data set of research papers
from the um nih
and then the second is how do you
develop a search engine in such a short
matter of time
and to answer that is to build and ex
build it upon an existing search engine
so in this case it's through pi cerini
and anserini which are data retrieval
toolkits
available on github
and cerrini is a retrieval toolkit from
the lucine search engine library it's
open source
and it has a lot of resources with um
multi-stage ranking
and in pi cerrini is
a more user-friendly interface to
anserini
it's
very efficient to use with first stage
retrieval
and it includes queries and relevance
judgments and indexes and evaluations
and other questions that are being
accounted for in this experiment is what
are the appropriate information
retrieval modalities for this experiment
how do you optimize a search engine for
more specific situations
you know because some people can just
enter some keywords and they'll get
results back but others other users will
enter something much more specific
so how will it accommodate for that
and further how can existing data be
used to improve the search engine
so how can
we potentially teach a search engine to
improve upon itself each time
other questions that are being accounted
for
is
if event specific training data can be
created fast enough to have an impact
how can you quantitatively measure
a search engine's efficiency
and
when comparing different types of search
algorithms
what are the what characteristics are
the most important to compare
and finally how does one qualitative
qualitatively evaluate the search engine
so the procedure for this project was
that participants were giving a corpus
which was the data set of all of the
documents to evaluate and they were also
giving a list of topics
that they would enter in as queries to
see
what documents would come up every time
they searched it up on
on their information retrieval system
and participants have one week to create
their own information retrieval system
and run one thousand results per topic
and after that results are gathered and
manually evaluated
and judges rank how relevant each topic
is
so in this experiment um
so once everything is evaluated
or once the judges got to the
evaluations
they went through each paper
and
they had um they had to sort if it was
relevant partially relevant or not
relevant
and this skill was used to determine um
how
this algorithm
how accurate it was and it also helped
them compare
um
compare them with one another
and here it shows on
for each topic
how relevant
um
each of the searches were
and here are the judgments that go with
them
and for the technique that was used for
this experiment was a pulling technique
so what they did was that
in order to save time they got the top
rank results from each participant
and then judges manually ranked how if
you know if it was
the best
document that the search engine could
have gotten or if it wasn't relevant or
if it was
or if it just didn't have anything to do
with the search query
so a difficulty that comes with this
project is
you know it's just the massive reports
that come in each day
it's really hard to maintain a current
data set and
it's also you know
if you want to stay current you have to
download it over and over again and you
have to update it and add more articles
and more
new statistics each day
and the second was the lack of qualified
judges to manually assess each article
these judges are experts in their field
these judges
um
and also need to make the time to judge
all of these different articles
so that's one difficulty that came with
this
and in hopes of solving these
difficulties um
you know the first is just repeating the
procedure and seeing um if anything if
any other issues or if any other
potential solutions come up
and it's with five topics each time five
new topics
and then there's also the possibility of
including machine learning techniques
in order to lessen the need of human
judges
which would be by um you know having the
search engine
build its own criteria and its own
standards on its own
and finally some personal takeaways that
i got from this project
was that i obtained a greater
understanding on information retrieval
methods
and i also got a greater insight on the
statistical methods that overlap with
bioinformatics
and i got experience with using github
and the repository and importing various
toolkits from it
and overall i just want to acknowledge
everyone who
um was a part of this project and i also
want to acknowledge dr hirsch
he um
provided a you know he helped a lot with
the background information of
this project and
he
also helped me understand a lot of these
concepts
a lot more better
you know they're very hard to grasp at
first but um
you know his explanations made them a
lot more easy
to um digest and i would also like to
thank dr chamberla
sorry dr chamberlain for from ohsu
um he was very helpful when it came to
syntax errors and any coding errors
that i encountered during this project
and i would also like to thank everybody
at demise for listening to my
presentation and for
giving me
uh this opportunity to
you know put my foot in the door when it
came to machine learning
and i'd also like to thank the
university at buffalo new york for
expanding my knowledge and the allen
institute for ai and microsoft research
for the funding on this project
thank you very much
great thank you
any questions from the audience
okay um
since um
since since i was your mentor i won't
ask you these ask you questions here
why don't we then
move on um to the third and final
presentation
um
i see that
dr dorr is still here
um but i think he wants his intern to um
introduce herself so i can turn over the
floor to
suzanne navarro
i am so sorry i forgot to unmute give me
a second please
okay
good morning everyone my name is suzanne
navarro and i'm a rising senior at
jesuit high school in the lovely city of
portland oregon
and today i'll be presenting on the
project i worked on this summer the
ecare plan app for patients with
multiple chronic conditions
problem
nearly one in three adults in america
are currently affected by multiple
chronic conditions otherwise known as
mccs for short
mccs disproportionately affect women
racial and ethnic minorities and
low-income individuals
as we know patients with multiple
conditions almost always see multiple
providers to help with each of their
conditions
a lack of care coordination amongst a
patient's providers all too frequently
results in wasted time and money as
shown in figure 13 we see that people
with six plus chronic conditions
represented in purple
make up the smallest percentage of
medicare beneficiaries at 17 percent
and yet they account for the greatest
percentage of medicare spending at 53
however
lack of care coordination most
importantly results in fragmented lower
quality care and sub-optimal health
outcomes for patients as evidenced by
figure 14.
figure 14 shows that those with six plus
chronic conditions are significantly
more likely to be readmitted within 30
days of a hospital visit
making up 81 percent of these readments
potential solution in improving health
information technology
in recent years ehr or electronic health
record systems have become widely
implemented in all different types of
healthcare settings
you may be familiar with epic or my
chart which are both ehr systems epic
being a provider facing system while my
chart is a
patient-facing system
and these ehr systems are a subset of
healthit healthit having greatly
improved care coordination among
providers and the clarity and
accessibility of medical data for
non-mcc patients
however there is little evidence that
health it has improved patient care for
mcc patients
the thought process behind this project
is that if we improve health i.t we may
be able to maximize benefits for mcc
patients
project goal
the project goal is to improve the
quality of care for mcc patients
especially those with chronic kidney
disease or ckd by improving ehr systems
the proposed solution for reaching this
goal was to build the ecare app an app
which will work in existing ehr
workflows will serve as a tool for both
providers and patients that contains the
patient's comprehensive care plan and
all of their medical data in one place
will enhance patient understanding of
their medical data and will emphasize
patient goals to providers
collaborators
there were many collaborating
institutions involved in this project
on the left there's a screenshot of a
slide from a deck of training slides
that i will introduce later
that summarizes the collaborators and
the roles very well
the niddk which is part of the nih
funded app development and cognitive
helped with the actual building of the
app
arc funded the testing and evaluation of
the app while rti international and ohsu
did the testing and evaluation
throughout this summer i attended many
zoom and webex meetings almost all of
them being meetings that recurred
frequently and got to experience and be
a part of the coordination that has to
happen between these collaborating
institutions on tasks deadlines and such
however there's one other resource that
was instrumental in this project and
that resource is known as fast
healthcare interoperability resources or
fire for short
and i might not be explaining this
perfectly but as one of my team members
on this project matt explained to me
code usually has to be rewritten for
each ehr system that uses it because ehr
systems almost always interact with and
store medical data in different ways
but fire solves this problem with its
framework as it standardizes data
formats and interactions so that ehr
code can be used on a variety of
platforms without having to be rewritten
fire is part of what makes this project
innovative populating the e-care plan
app with data from epic
the bottom right picture shows the fire
workflow
methods
first both provider and patient patient
facing versions of the ecare plan app
were built
here is a screenshot of what the health
status evaluation and outcomes page of
the app looks like in the provider
facing app to the left
and to the right
is a screenshot of the corresponding
page in the patient facing app
next a lot of preparation for usability
testing of the app was done
but before we get into that however
i wanted to briefly introduce what this
usability testing entails
it entails having facilitators such as
myself and my team member taylor
observing providers walking through the
app and getting their feedback on it
in preparation for this usability
testing a simulation patient dubbed
patricia noel was designed to be the
archetypal patient that would have this
app as part of their care
she has mcc advanced ckd and multiple
care teams across healthcare settings
the team the ecare
app team that is created three different
progressive medical scenarios for
patricia noel in order to test all
aspects of the app
to the right you can see a screenshot of
patricia's scenarios complete with
medications referrals and more
in addition because of her medical
conditions and medical data when she is
used to test the app the team will
immediately know if the ecare plan app
isn't working the way it should
and since i use these terms quite often
throughout the remainder of this
presentation i thought i'd mention that
the term usability testing is
essentially synonymous with user
acceptance testing or uat
a uat form was created to guide said
testing as it contains all of the
questions that the facilitators of the
usability testing ask participants in
order to get their feedback
and i'll talk more about usability
testing soon but these questions were
agreed upon by several of the project's
collaborators and were crafted so as to
make uat as structured and efficient as
possible
here's a screenshot of a section of the
current uat form which has gone through
many many revisions
another thing that was done to prepare
for usability testing was making a data
collection form
i made one in smartsheet and it had to
go through several revisions before we
started scheduling uat sessions
i used it to collect provider feedback
during uat and it made collecting and
interpreting feedback extremely
efficient
figuring out how to make this form so
the data would be easiest to interpret
and compare after collection took some
thought
on this slide
you can see a screenshot of said
smartsheet form
one more thing that was done as
preparation for uit was the making of
training materials for those learning to
use the app
these materials include tip sheets
training sessions and training slides
all meant to help those using the app
feel more comfortable with it
on the top right you can see a
screenshot of part of a tip sheet made
by taylor complete with guiding
instructions and arrows
towards the bottom is a training slide
from the training slide deck made by rti
international to be used in training
sessions that tells providers what to
expect during uat
uat was conducted and involved
scheduling hour-long blocks of time with
providers and getting their feedback on
matters such as functionality usability
and how helpful the contents of the app
would be for patient care
uat helps us see how easy the app is to
use for those who don't have as much
experience with it as well as how
helpful the app is and would be for
patients with mcc
and this usability testing was done in
the app's test and live environments
the test environment for the
provider-facing app can be accessed
through epic poc and the test
environment for the patient-facing app
can be accessed through mychart poc
both environments are populated with
patricia noel's medical data
the provider facing apps live
environment conversely is accessible
through epic production and is populated
with real patient data
the real patients whose data was chosen
for usability testing had to meet the
following inclusion criteria
that they were the
participating providers patient so the
provider could tell us if something
wasn't showing on the app
and that they had mcc's at least one of
which is ckd so as to test the app to
the fullest extent
and before we move on to the next slide
i'd just like to quickly note that all
team members that interacted with real
patient data were trained to work with
it so that there would be no breaches of
privacy of any sort
also
the top picture shows how
the app can be accessed through epic
whether that's epic poc or epic
production
and the bottom screen shot shows how the
ecare plan app would be accessed through
mychart poc
and over the next few slides i provided
screenshots of the pages of the
provider-facing app
and i'll pause for a few seconds before
i continue on to the next slide but here
are the
first two pages of the app
and here are the next two and i have
these in order by the way
and here is the last page
and hopefully seeing the pages of the
app gives you a better sense of what we
were asking of providers doing during
your uat
findings
app strengths across the board the app
was found by participating providers to
be intuitive to navigate and use
these providers thought the app would
prove useful for more efficient and
effective reviews of patient data and
goals before visits
several of them citing the diagnoses
labs and vitals including trends and
goals focus areas as most useful in this
respect
overall these providers agree that the
app will add substantial value to
patient care
app limitations
however there are a few problems within
the app
there were some app down times during
uat some of which were expected and
others that were unexpected
so two of our providers that were part
of our initial round of uat needed to be
partially rescheduled
also additional labs that we knew should
have been showing were missing and
medications were slow to load for some
of the more complicated patients
and by complicated i mean that these
patients had more data than the app was
used to at that point in time
goals were also usually missing from
live patients
furthermore users requested to see
comments from other providers and nurses
in order to get additional detail not
already recorded in the app about
for example how good a patient had been
with taking their medications
here are three of the five app pages
that i showed you before
and these are the three focus areas that
i mentioned as being the provider's
favorites
the providers specifically liked that
pages one and four shown as the first
and third screenshots on this slide
they like these
pages because of their consolidation of
key data while preserving necessary
specificity especially for the diagnoses
part of the first screenshot
and test results in the third screenshot
here
in the
tables and the charts
they also thought that the goals section
under page 2 was really helpful
and pretty innovative as patient goals
are not something that
they are accustomed to seeing in other
ehr systems like epic
resulting changes
based on this first round of uat some
changes were made
as i briefly mentioned before we had
been scheduling hour-long blocks of time
for uat
and at this point in time they became
30-minute sessions for the sake of
efficiency
in order to shorten the uat accordingly
i helped with condensing and eliminating
some questions in the uat form and
smartsheet
with these changes made we found that
these 30-minute sessions worked
wonderfully during our second round of
uat
furthermore ohsu and cognitive fix the
app so that additional labs now show for
live patients
i got to help with checking the app's
logs in order to track down what errors
were occurring within the app
during the process of getting this fixed
i did a fair amount of testing the app
so i could ensure things had been fixed
especially for some of the more
complicated patients
testing the app involved being pretty
well versed in epic for example i would
check to see if the labs in the
patient's epic chart matched with those
showing in the app and that they were
showing all the results that they should
have been
i did extensive testing with several
different patients in order to test the
app to the fullest extent
both with patricia noel and poc and with
several real patients in production
with the real patients i found some
inconsistencies between the app and epic
and compiled them into a spreadsheet and
then made a word doc with screenshots
and notes on the problems both of which
helped with debugging the app
a lot of the problems that i found
relating to data missing from the app
have been due to problems with
fireworking improperly as fire is still
a relatively new tool
and here's a snippet of the excel
spreadsheet that i was talking about
except without the patient medical
record numbers or mrns showing because
those are easily identifiable
i would show you the aforementioned
screenshots and notes document but it
has a lot of personal health information
and it would be hard to adequately
redact
future steps future steps for this
project include continuing to conduct
uat with more providers from
pre-selected clinics and having these
providers train patients they selected
on how to use the patient-facing app
these actions will complete the full
rollout of the app to these
pre-recruited clinics
furthermore creating a video walkthrough
of the app to account for app down times
has been deemed a necessary fallback for
uat
both bullets one and three are currently
in the works
project takeaways
a lot goes into projects like these that
involve so many people at various
institutions
there's lots to keep on top of and i
never would have anticipated how many
meetings i would be attending but it's
definitely necessary in order to keep
everyone up to speed on what's happening
in different areas of the project
also my team tracks conferences grants
and manuscripts something i didn't
expect at all coming into this project
because of this i was able to
participate in submitting an abstract
about our project to the academy health
science of dissemination and
implementation in health conference at
dr door suggestion
i am currently in the process of
submitting to another conference as well
my last big takeaway is when you're
working with so many people and
especially with something as volatile as
technology
be prepared for things to go wrong and
for things to come up or need
improvements
being flexible and having backup plans
in place is key when working on projects
like this one
and here are my citations
and as i conclude my presentation i
would like to give a very special thank
you to dr dore my mentor to matt mj and
taylor a few of the members of the ecare
plan app team
the rest of the ecare and cmp teams
and to dmice they all made this
internship such a great experience and
have been so eager to help and have been
so welcoming
and this concludes my presentation for
today are there any questions
great thank you
any questions from the audience
well if not actually i will maybe ask
you the same question i asked ellie um
again um noting that um
the development of of these standards
like fire is
something that many of us who've been
working this field and for a long time
um see us as such a positive development
did you find any um
shortcomings
it sounds like um you you mentioned it
on one of your slides when you're doing
the usability evaluation shortcomings in
um fire
um the standard and
if so what did you find
um
i mostly i wasn't doing this first hand
but i was getting a lot of input from
the people that kind of were more
involved than me
and what was happening was that fire
wasn't collecting all of the information
that it should have been and sending it
to the app
and this would happen
when there were fire down times so it
was unexpected
and
especially with usability testing that
we pre-schedule about a week and a half
to two weeks in advance
we couldn't really
like account for that and we would just
kind of be in the middle of usability
testing and we would have to say like
sorry we do not know why this isn't
showing it was showing a day ago so
great
any other
questions
comments
um great if not well um i so this um
pretty much brings our um
2021
um internship uh year to a close the
interns will still be around a little
bit longer um finishing up their
projects and getting ready to go back to
school um it's great that
at least we got to have the internship
this year because last year was
cancelled at the
beginning of the pandemic and this year
it had to be virtual
um maybe next year we'll
be back back to normal
but
it sounds like all of the interns both
those who presented today and last week
had
valuable experiences and and that is
good to hear
um to uh
to have
those of you in college in high school
uh experience our field of biomedical
informatics
so um
thank you everyone for attending and um
we'll see you at our next conference
have a good day bye
bye